I can confirm that at approximately 2:00
p.m. today Friday the 29th of November
police were called to a stabbing at a
premises near two London Bridge EC one
emergency services attended including
officers from the City of London Police
and the Metropolitan Police
and male suspect was shot by specialist
armed officers from the city of London
police and I can confirm that this
suspect died at the scene a number of
other people received injuries during
this incident as soon as we can provide
further updates on their condition we
will and our heartfelt sympathies go out
to everybody who's been involved in this
and is anxiously waiting for information
on their loved ones as soon as we can
get that information we will get it to
you as you would expect due to the
nature of the incident we responded as
though this was terrorist related I'm
now in a position to confirm that it has
been declared a terrorist incident we
are working jointly with the city of
London police as we continue to respond
officers from the Metz counterterrorism
command are now leading this
investigation but I must stress we
retain an open mind as to any motive it
would be inappropriate to speculate
further at this time due to reports that
the suspect may have had an explosive
device specialist officers also attended
the same and wide cordons are in place
to ensure there remains no further
danger to the public however I can
confirm at this time we believe a device
that was strapped to the body of the
suspect is a hoax explosive device
officers continue to carry out
meticulous searches in the area to
ensure there is no outstanding threat to
the public those extensive Corden's will
remain in place for a considerable time
and I would ask the public please
continue to avoid the area public safety
is obviously our top priority we will be
enhancing police patrols both in the
city and across London I would ask
anyone with information image or footage
of the incident that can be shared with
our investigation team to do so on the
UK police image appeal website I would
also ask the public to continue to
remain vigilant and report any concerns
that they have to the police
I know I would ordinarily take questions
I'm not going to take questions at this
time the Prime Minister has asked for a
personal briefing and I'll be heading
with the Commissioner of the Met to
Downing Street immediately thank you for
your patience we will update you again
when we can